ce sera parfait pour la soirée
échangiste tu veux parler de la soirée
troc la soirée où on échange les objets
on y songe quand même avec plaisir
d donc pas rentrer tard à les soirées
échangistes ça traîne toujours en
longueur
et soirée et ce soir ils sont juste
parce que bon le bridge scrabble au bout
d'un moment
vous fais ça depuis quand mais ça fait
des années
je sais déjà que mon mari lui il aimait
porte ils trouvent eux qui avaient trop
de dieu bon effectivement ce serait
mieux c'est plus de jeunes ça vous
dirait de venir non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah je faisais un coup c'est cette soirée
m'a cassé les pâtes
[Musique]
le fait